the question is prove
by mathematical induction and what do
they want us to do
um 8 to the n plus 2
lots of 7 to the n minus 1.
they want us to prove that it has a
factor
of seven or that it's divisible by seven
you guys get that it's the same
it's the same idea right okay good so um
let's just
proceed as we usually do i should have
mentioned the allowable values
some of them actually start at zero
which is interesting but this one is
normal so just natural numbers okay so
our first step of course is to test so
what's our first valuable value it's
just one
so i get eight to the one plus two lots
of seven to the one
minus one okay so that's eight plus
fourteen minus one so that's twenty one
so that checks out good
so now i make my assumption uh which is
this 4k so i've got 8 to the k
plus 2 lots of 7 to the k minus 1
and i'll let that equal to something
and i should introduce the two numbers
that i've just
started talking about okay and they've
got their conditions on them which we've
noticed before
sometimes that's really important to how
you do your proof okay
now i'm going to move this over what do
i actually
want to prove of the basis of that
assumption the next case over which is
just
k plus 1 because you guys have noticed
when it's sometimes k plus 2 or
chemistry or whatever
so this is what i want k plus 1
plus 2 lots of 7 to the k plus 1 minus 1
equals some other positive
integer all right
excuse me all right now so far so good
lots of different approaches that we
could use this is an inequality or
anything like that
what you see here and what we're
required to prove it looks like i think
i can find the assumption somewhere in
there if i twist and turn it enough
so i'm going to start with the left hand
side i'm going to say
well first i know i've noticed there's
people who have been writing
they've been a bit like they've skipped
lines and they've just started working
with it straight away it's a bad idea
the proof has to be really watertight
okay so i'm just going gonna write it
out verbatim
so now i've got eight lots of eight to
the k there
i've got two lots of seven lots
of seven to the k there so that's just
my index laws
yes okay now the reason why i would do
that is because
the assumption has doesn't have k plus
ones in it it's got eight to the k
two seven to the k and i can see those
there the question is well how many do i
have
so i've got eight here
and how many of these do i have i've got
14 don't i mm-hmm
14 of those
minus 1. okay now the question then
becomes right how can i
how much of the assumption can i see is
present
here how much can i see
now i can see well yeah i can have seven
of them i can take out seven and i'll
have some leftovers won't i
okay so if i say let's take out those
seven
i'm going to have one of them there
and then i'll have 7 times 8 to the k
there which lines up with that term
then i've got my i've got
7 lots of that already so i'll just i'll
just leave that b
and then i've got minus one okay all
right
now here's the thing though this this
assumption has a has a one in it right
so i need if i want seven lots of this
i'll have seven of these fourteen of
these so far so good
but i need negative seven there when i
okay so that's
minus seven but i can't just change that
to a minus seven
can i add six so i'll add six okay
so now what do i do what can i actually
do so
i can take out a factor of seven here
okay so that'll leave me with eight to
the k
plus two times 7 to the k
minus 1 okay plus
what was left over which was this and
this
okay i made a mistake now um the reason
why i could tell i wonder if you could
tell
why i made a mistake i looked at this
now you often get to um
to this point in induction proofing you
think okay i either have
um there's something about this that i
don't know okay
or i've done something wrong right now i
did um i was a bit naughty i should have
said by assumption there
oh no no it's okay i haven't actually
subbed it in yet i haven't subbed in my
3p
um wait 3p why do i say 2p that should
be seven
yeah okay that's a minor thing now
here's the thing though
this this is not going to factorize
nicely if this factorizes nicely like we
expect this should too but i'm
i've got a problem okay so instead of
this
i'm going to try something else i've
obviously got to reshape this line
in some different way that makes that
factor of 7 easier to pull out
okay now we tried pulling out 7 lots of
the assumption
but that wasn't very useful to us okay
so what else could we try
now you can take out however many number
of the assumptions you like
some are more useful than others right
so for instance from here
suppose i just took out one suppose i
just took out one
now one of the reasons why you might say
one is because i just have a negative
one
there don't i okay so if i just take out
one of these what will be left over well
i'm gonna have seven lots of a to the k
and then
one lot of a to the k ah that's
interesting right i'm looking for sevens
aren't i
then i've got i'm going to pull out one
of these
from here if i pull out one lot of that
from here i'll let i'll be left with 12
seven to the k is that okay right plus
two lots of seven of k i don't know why
i started writing brackets anyway
um there's my eight to the k is that
kind of four there's my seven decays a
count of four
minus one okay so now
i've got let me use this i've got this
guy
and i've got this guy and this guy
that's exactly what my assumption is
right so therefore i can sub them all
out for
7p can't i seven
p now what's left over i've got 7 times
8 to the k and i've got 12 times 7 to
the k
by the assumption you guys need to write
that out in four i've just ran out of
space
okay well that's it that's it isn't it
well it's almost it so let me take out a
factor seven
right and then what's going to be left
well i've got p
that's an integer that's good i've got
eight to the k that's integer that's
good
now what happens here
i've got 12 times what well
because i've taken out a factor of 7
this is going to be 7
times k to the minus one now that you
have to be careful of
right because depending on like negative
indices are a bad idea we're this is a
this is a divisibility proof so i want
everything to be in whole numbers don't
i
okay so i can't just ignore this guy i
can say
this is um this is a positive integer no
problems
this is a positive integer no problems
but this guy on what grounds can i argue
12 times 7 to the k minus 1 will be an
integer and i have
to appeal back to what i specify k can
be so the very smallest that k can be is
1
the very smallest it can be so that
would make the smallest value that this
takes
12 times seven to the power of
zero so that's twelve that's twelve
isn't it twelve times one
so that's good and of course as i take
subsequent values of k
it just gets bigger from there and it
stays um
a whole number okay so being that all of
these pieces
are whole numbers therefore i can say
that's 7q
where q is equal to all of that rubbish
inside the brackets
because that's what it looks like okay
so there now it's true for the next case
um using the assumption and you can sort
of carry it from there and just finish
off with your explanation
so it's actually kind of handy that i
made an error there because when you get
to a point like this you often we just
give up don't we right but that tells us
okay
i used the assumption great but i didn't
use it in a way that was helpful because
there are helpful ways and there are
unhelpful ways
okay